i became totally addicted to our next
guest delicious content on his social
media and i did something i don't really
even know how to do i slid into his dms
because i was such a fan i wanted to
just personally reach out and ask him to
be on the show he has almost 2 million
followers between instagram and tick
tock and his cookbook
jewish reinvented recipes from a modern
mensch
is filled with recipes that everyone can
enjoy please welcome jake cohen
i'm so excited to be here
i
i just stand grow up so hard on chefs
and i watch everything you do and i just
think you know the way you bring
cultures and culinary adventures
together you have such a unique take
thank you thank you and you're ashkenazi
seinfeld larry david curb your
enthusiasm you know the drill but you
met your husband
um on
hinge on new year's day yeah
2015. yes yeah and you celebrate his
culture into your food as well right i
think that's that was
the inspiration for this book was the
fact that we were two jewish kids who
had completely different different
different definitions of jewish food he
had never had babka he had never had
matsupal soup and i never had the dishes
that he grew up eating for the same
holiday and your husband's here of
course i bring him everywhere
[Applause]
i mean
do you have something to say for
yourself and the way that you can give
anyone out there who is surfing those
dating apps and has lost hope
i mean drew like before jake i dated so
many duds and then jake and i met and we
literally from the the new year's day
date that we had we spent every night
together since then um and it's been
love ever since and like i coded more
than anything
thank you for sharing that story i think
people have got to keep hope alive and
romance is the greatest and we're all
contending with the relationship of some
sort
exactly okay now um
i am so excited i am your student teach
me how to make this fabulous dish this
is one of my favorite like desserts for
it and it's good for all fall it's an
apples and honey upside down cake you
really like it wows your guests all
right take it away so we're gonna start
we got our cake pan here with apples
making a little concentric circle let's
just we got a few extra to fill in the
center
and now the real fun part is the caramel
so making a caramel it's pretty pretty
easy you just have to be patient and you
can't touch it that's the the key part
is you're shaking it but you shouldn't
be stirring it like that bad bad
the trick is literally like this what
that could do
what's that do that's hot be careful
the trick is as you're making it you
just shake your pan we're going to pour
this right over our apples
see this is the definition of
mellifluous i love that i like word of
the day with drew barrymore or like
honey they equate it to music this sort
of
fluidity this melody this beauty
poetic
beautiful i may not know caramel but i
know that dictionary
so we're gonna put that to the side and
now we're gonna deal with the cake
batter okay so right here we have a bowl
with two eggs and we're gonna just start
throwing everything in so half a cup of
brown sugar full cup of honey three
quarters a cup of butter milk
and two sticks of butter that i browned
and i love the honey because it adds
such like a floral quality
the buttermilk is going to add a bit of
richness some fat but also acidity i
love baking with buttermilk because it
helps react with the baking soda and
baking powder for a nice like fluffy
cake now i'm emulsifying it as i'm going
you're going yeah you're going wild um
it's all good i mean it's not that
not that precious i know i like i try
not to take anything too seriously in
the kitchen even with baking and now
it's flour baking soda baking powder
some cinnamon and nutmeg and a lot of
salt you gotta have the salt your dry
ingredients exactly and you fold it in
exactly
[Applause]
okay
i feel really good
endlessly customizable we can use any
fruit depending on the season let's say
it's like in the summer sometimes i'll
swap out the cinnamon nutmeg for like
lavender or lemon zest
a while oh i love this
then we just pour it on top
you don't need a frosting you can have
it be this like
table side i always think of like a
tableside flambe this gives that same
vibes of having something that's so
you put a lot of energy into it and
people love that people love to try a
dish that
had a little bit of work put in this is
gorgeous oh my gosh the batter
oh my god
i have to i'm going inside
the brown butter the brown butter
oh my
[Applause]
completely forgot where i was for a
second i'm back from here we just pop it
into a 350 degree oven for an hour and
then
the number one secret for an upside down
kick is when you do that flip which
which i will warn you
is like
you have to hold your breath and really
pray a little
you have to let the cake cool for 15
minutes before you flip it pray and flip
try and flip and this is what you get
it really is something that is
so
it's so beautiful but it's actually much
much easier than people think we have
our we got extra slices you want to eat
the whole thing this is your show i just
i finished with some whipped cream and a
little honey oh my god i'm like oh whoa
okay
i put a lot of honey on but we're good
the apples
oh my god it is moist oh my gosh this is
the best compliment you could ever get
as being
well your cake at least because
nobody wants anything dry let's face
that oh god this is so good and it was
like fall this is full
oh jake
thank you
for allowing me to cyber stalk you oh
god anytime and not be like off put but
actually show up and contribute to our
show i'm such a fan and i would love to
do more with you whatever we'll make
banana fosters next bananas
oh my god you don't understand
all right you heard it here first my
favorite thing in the world and i've
never understood how to make them so
could we do that because that's the
craziest dm story so i've become friends
not only with you on social but with
katie couric oh
i love her i heard you brought her matzo
ball soon literally she was sick and we
were chatting she was a big supporter of
the book and i was like let me bring you
some possible soup so you are the next
one pick up my balls
i want you to teach me the way of the
ball gotcha
jake cohen be sure to pick up a copy of
his beautiful cookbook which is out now
jewish
[Music]